i don't see barriers hard work every day
is a lifestyle
it should be like a standard dedication
attention to detail
i just wanted to be the best i was that
obsessed with it my kids lost they lost
their
their mum i got to understand mental
health for making a documentary it's
allowed me to kind of speak and
show vulnerability that people probably
were never used to the great part of it
is that you walk down the street an old
age lady or a man come up to you you
know what
throat's all croaky and i watched your
program
i've never spoken before really you
helped me
like my next phase of my life when
someone sees me in
10 20 years say that's where i paid for
my united i haven't really done what i'm
here to do to set and setting out to do
do i even need to introduce my next
guest rio
ferdinand former football player one of
the most decorated
english footballers of all time and as a
man united fan probably one of my
favorite players
of all time ever and he's played
alongside some of the greatest players
ever
but he's also been managed by the best
manager ever
i grew up as a manchester united fan
watching him idolizing him
and now he's my mate so this is going to
be a fairly
interesting conversation after retiring
he's become a sports commentator for bt
sport he's become
an author he's become an entrepreneur
he's the founder of a charity a
foundation
he's a non-executive director which
we'll talk about today as well
and as you'll hear he's also so much
more some things that you probably
wouldn't expect
he's also a husband and a dad one that's
experienced
tremendous unthinkable tragedy tragedy i
pray that most of us will never know
rio is a special guy not least for what
he's achieved on the field but for who
he is and today you're going to find out
who he
actually is the philosophy to life that
he swears by
and the culture required to win in an
ambitious career but also
the culture required to win in your
personal life
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the director ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
i'm trying to find the right words to
ask this question because it's one that
i've i haven't seen been asked in
previous interviews with you but what
are the what are the key things that
happened
when you were very very young that made
you
choose football as your future or
enabled you to to take that path because
a lot of kids grow up in london a lot of
kids do a lot of things they have a lot
of passions but for some reason
as i read through your story football
was this
ballet as well but football was the the
path that you chose to take
above all other things yeah it's a good
question because when i was younger i
was into everything
i was running around on the estate i was
doing gymnastics
a couple of times a week i was doing
ballet i was obviously playing football
i was doing athletics
i was doing a drama class why were you
doing all those things there because i
just was interested
in it all i liked it i enjoyed it and my
mum and dad were really my mom
especially were really like if you like
something go and do it
try it they were always like that go and
do it what's
the worst it can do is you you don't
enjoy it i used to do karate sometimes
as well
and i got to a point i think i was like
13 or 14 years old and obviously my dad
was having to come from east like
obviously we lived in south london he'd
drive to east northeast london
drive home pick me up from school take
me to west london to play football
back to dropping friends off on the way
is hard graft
and in the end i got to 13 14 years old
and my dad said listen
you're doing a lot at the moment you're
going to burn yourself out so
let's just pick something that you
really enjoy and you want to do
and just go for it and i was like it was
that an easy
conversation it was difficult you know i
had to let down our fault
and disappoint central school of ballet
where i was doing it which is a real
like a top score in london in farringdon
and i made good friends there and
the other stuff i wasn't too that
concerned about it but
four years i was three or four years i
was at the central school of ballet so
i've got
good relationships there told them i
couldn't do it and then
went full throttle and full steam ahead
of with football and it was just
it was the best decision i obviously
made
in my life in that sense but i was i
knew that that was my passion
i liked the other stuff i enjoyed doing
the other stuff there were good
distractions from what was probably
going on my estate as well probably my
parents fault like that as well
but football was the something that i
got up every day from when i knocked on
my friend's ass
borrow ship or let's go and play
football et cetera so
ballet hmm interesting one a lot of
people don't know
that you did ballet and i but it sounds
like you did at a pretty good level
yeah i've done gymnastic gymnastics at
the london olympic games and they
obviously i didn't notice there were
scouts there
from from ballet schools or someone was
watching our family and friend was there
and they said ah
he looks like he i don't know how what i
had or what i was
my posture or something like that looks
good to be a ballet dancer
so i went there and i wasn't really one
for saying no to stuff i was like
i'll try it i'll try anything and they
said and one of the reasons i was going
to be able to get off my estate
meet new people new girls maybe as a
young kid
and then it was in a different part of
london traveling
so i've done it it's funny i read i read
a tweet the other day which was kind of
linked to something you said there and
it said on the way up say yes to
everything
when you get to the top start saying no
to everything yeah yeah and it sounds
like yeah and it's like and i'm almost
saying that as well when we the
conversation we're having now about like
the stuff you're up to now
now yeah like what is what's that i
always think this what's the worst way
that can happen as long as it's not a
health issue
i might fail i might i might not be good
at it i might have foul who cares like
with a boxing
i wanted to go trying to be from a
professional footballer just trying to
be a professional boxer
crazy yeah but what's the worst that can
really happen
i lose the fight my life goes on that's
it so
but some people they can't allow their
ego to be
squashed maybe at a certain point or
their pride
and they're sitting there as this macho
person that they can't
feel vulnerable at any point and when
you try things
there is an element of vulnerability
that comes with that because you're
opening yourself up you're leaving
yourself a bit wide open
for criticism for failure but i'm not
scared of failure
i never have been i'm not i'm not
fearful and that's what i try and put in
my kids
if you fail what get up and go again
people like they they trap themselves in
their career in their sense their sort
of self-identity because
we were talking before we started
chatting about like me trying to resist
my labels now i've left social chain
they think they are an x but from a very
very young age and i'm kind of
connecting the dots now through the rest
of your life and even now
you worse you were a kid on the estate
in peckham
and that is an identity that's not one
that's also conducive with ballet
no is that it's just such a different
end of the spectrum yeah like you just
wouldn't associate one with the other
and again i i wasn't we were speaking
just as you mentioned before before he
came on here
one of the things that i my mom used to
say to me is that don't let anyone tell
you what you are
don't be pigeon holed i mean you go and
find out and explore and find out what
you are
and you gotta have experiences to get to
that point it's not gonna happen
overnight it's not gonna happen in your
childhood
not in your teens when you get to become
an adult you'll start working your way
and finding out who you are and what you
are
and i've always thought that so going to
a ballet school i could have been
ridiculed
my mates i was one of the boys on the
estate but at the same time i was
confident enough that
i really again ballet laughing i don't
care what
and i know i'm good at football i know
i'm good i'm the fastest runner on the
estate in my age group
i can keep up with the older boys what
because i go badly what there's nothing
wrong
who are you to answer that question you
know your mum's telling you to go out
and find out who you are
did you ever answer that question not
really i think that question you don't
really answer it in the end i think
you're always evolving it's like for
instance it's something you said earlier
it
pricked my ears about you said moles the
same thing just in a different way
probably a more elegant way about not
wanting to be pigeonholed and
like my aim in my life now like people
think you've played football and you've
done all these amazing things as a
footballer
i i've done really well i acknowledge
that but
it's like understatement but i don't
that's not enough for me
like my next phase of my life i don't
want to be remember when someone sees me
my success in my next phase of life is
when someone sees me and says that's rio
do you know rio
and they mentioned something that i'm
doing or i've done around that time
not that's rio's a footballer if people
were in
10 20 years say that's where i paid for
my united
i ain't really kicked on i haven't
really done what i'm
i'm here to do to setting out to do
which is to evolve and become something
different
and make something of myself somewhere
else and i think my my family were a lot
like that whether my mum and dad was
successful or not
they were always to us make something of
yourself be something
nothing there's no there's no barriers
to that so that's the way i've always
kind of
thought about things what if it what if
i said to you
now how would you feel if i said you
couldn't ever do anything else and that
like the football thing was it and now
just
i just laugh i'd laugh it would make me
laugh because i i don't see no
i don't see barriers yeah and
unfortunate as well by the way i
understand that i've got to a position
where there are a lot of boundaries that
have been kind of put down
yeah yeah for me to skip over because of
my career as a footballer
yeah and you you're getting that now as
someone who's been really successful in
your field so
you see that color and age et cetera get
put to the side because i
always we acknowledge what you've done
yeah yeah yeah and so we do sometimes
have a easy there's not as big a barrier
to entry for certain things for us but
then you've still got to go in and
produce
you've still got to go and prove
yourself and so even things that i've
i've gone on the board now for a company
the gym group as a ned oh really yeah
which is
it's out of my comfort zone because i
like
fitness but i don't understand the
business behind that and what goes into
having actual having 125 180 sites
and managing that and there's a property
arm and there's a commercial run and
there's a market
and that all coming together under one
umbrella and having to manage all that
and to be a part of those conversations
like
that stuff is what excite i i'm super
interested in that type of stuff
in the workings behind the mechanics of
all these type of businesses different
different industries
so that's what i like do you feel like
you're depth
yeah but i always find something what i
can clear on to that
i just try and find something within a
conversation that would
allow me to to to to gain confidence
through talking in that conversation
i might not understand everything and
when the conversation's finished and the
laptop's closed i'll
i'll be somewhere looking and finding
out i didn't understand that i'll call
that person back or call someone on that
on that call
just to clear up a few things i haven't
quite grasped
but there'll be something within that
conversation where i feel that i can add
some sort of value
i think all of that is a com is a very
again very synonymous as to why you're
like even sat here today because a lot
of people
in that situation would a just [ __ ]
avoid it from the jump
and then b if they encounter something
they don't understand on the call
they'll probably bounce then or
they definitely wouldn't inquire because
by inquiring you're actually making
yourself vulnerable
yeah yeah a lot of people don't want to
avoid vulnerability right being exposed
and it's so funny that the people that
from what i'm hearing from you like the
people that achieve the most success
are the ones that are at some point
willing to look [ __ ] stupid yeah you
gotta do that like no one gets to
where they're gonna get on the cleanest
without a bump on the road yeah you
don't get
like that you have to have bumps in the
road to be able to get there to
experience them
vulnerable moments so that when you are
there you know what it's like
and then you can drag people up with you
yeah yeah and you become stronger with
more
people that's how i always think there's
a lot of people when i get to the top
and stay on the top of the mountain on
their own and don't want to bring no one
up i don't agree with that
i'm always like i want to share and help
and because that
is the foundations of me being stronger
for a longer period of time and can
sustain
success but it is it is
i don't know it's another an important
thing for me as well which i'm
again i'm never scared to do is to ask
questions
like it's the same thing with football
you don't understand something my
manager's telling you our coach is
telling you
don't go away and and have a bit of a
blurred
idea of what it is because then you're
going to be judged on that
not understanding and not executing it's
going to repeat
exactly so you want good habits but
you've got to understand what it is
before you can create a habit
so that's why i'll try and always ask
questions if i'm if i'm wrong if
i feel i'm not sure and i'll definitely
ask questions not crazy
you've achieved all the success you're a
football legend and yet you're still
voluntarily
throwing yourself into really
uncomfortable situations which you don't
need to be in
yeah in terms of finance anyway like you
don't need to be at all in terms of like
a
status you don't need to be there and
it's funny because
there's loads of people that aren't
haven't achieved that that are
that will never throw themselves into
uncertainty
but it's it's but again this is probably
why they're the ones that stay where
they are yeah exactly that's probably
why you sat here
yes they don't grow they don't yeah and
like and all those people who will stay
there some of them are like oh i just
want to stay here but
a lot of them they're scared to open up
because of that vulnerability and them
feeling silly
if they're told that you got it wrong
but it's not
i i'm not like that everyone's on this
earth for different reasons and then
some people happy just to be
like stay in a situation they're in and
be very happy just
going along that that road and no spikes
or drops
i i'd rather have a drop at some point
but to get i know that spike's gonna
come somewhere
through being able to do the things
we're talking about
quick one starting from the minute the
lockdown is lifted we're going to start
bringing in some of our subscribers to
watch how this podcast is produced
behind the scenes
means you get to meet the guests meet
myself and see how we put all of this
together
if you want that to be you all you've
got to do hit the subscribe button
in your in your group front group chat
with your friends from uh
from your estate i heard there's a group
chat um you've been doing the research
i didn't need to research your career
because i was there watching but just
you know
it was i was intrigued by when you said
you got this group chat with your your
friends from back home and stuff and one
of the
topics of conversation is something that
i talk about a lot in this podcast which
is
there's a growing culture of like
softness
there i say it and like avoiding
discomfort and
also there's this crazy thing on
instagram at the moment which is like
demonizing hard work as if it's like
because of the mental health
revolution we've had and everyone's
which is a great thing and everyone's
aware of the impact
you know of this thing called mental
health there's now this other thing
which is like
well you can overwork and you can burn
yourself out and hard work if i advise
as an entrepreneur
even though i've never met someone or
had anyone sit in the seat who didn't
work hard
then i'm somewhat toxic because i'm
telling people that's
success and hard work yeah yeah and it's
like you're you're you're looking down
on people
yeah almost like and i listen i don't
agree with none of that
i've got to be honest work hard man that
should be just an
absolute normal ask of any person and
that and that i always keep talking
about my kids because
they're a big part of my life but that's
all i talk about my kids when they talk
to me about school
football washing up you chill that's
what's been one of the great things that
we've had a lot of negativity about
the covid uh situation in this country
staying at home etc at home schooling
and one of the great things to come out
of it for us as a family
these kids know their chores and they're
doing them properly and that's why i say
do your choice right because them habits
there will lead on to
other things in your life going forward
your football stuff you won't take short
short cuts you're taking shortcuts over
your work shortcuts for your football
shortcuts make in your bed shortcuts
with your school work homework et cetera
it will all be the same you need high
standards everywhere but are you scared
that
because they've grown up within a
different circumstance to what you had
well i always have you true this
conversation what you're not going to
say
yeah like i'm trying to instill that in
in them
how do you do that when they live that's
like a really nice house and they've got
that is
that is the guy who comes up with this
the the the answers for that
is the main man right because it's so
difficult i was doing a podcast
yesterday with um
eddie hearn oh yeah and he's like the
generation my children are so his father
was
well off successful and he was where my
children are now and he was saying like
one of the things that he was he was
scared of being that rich kid
yeah which i mean and so he done
everything not to go out and work
and to go and have a hard hard
hard-working mentality and to
be a success himself our friend tomorrow
is the same um
exactly so um all three of them by the
way i like that all three of them
come on your kids which i mean they are
exactly the same in terms of
they've gone out to they never had to
work their parents
would spoil them and they've all
knuckled down and said yeah we've been
given an opportunity
now you've got to go and execute and
they've gone executed beyond belief yeah
and i see
mahmoud who's of boohoo
who's the father of omar and the guys
and that's what i say to a man you must
be so happy man
what do you mean your kids man what
they're doing
how hard they work created these wicked
businesses but you gave them
opportunity but what they've done with
that you can't you can't be disappointed
he said no man he said that
for me to sit here and just see them
what they're doing what they're doing
that's where i want to be man
and it doesn't matter how much money you
make or how big of a business business
my success as a parent is that my kids
get up every day
they got a work ethic and they do stuff
to the best of their ability if they can
if they do that whether whatever job
they're in
they do that and i think you've done
you've laid the foundations for good
a good life for your kids whether it's
in
you know you talk there about having
high standards been one of the really
important things for your kids
this is something that clearly you know
was demonstrated when you got to old
trafford
and you joined manchester united um with
for that record transfer
but how did how did they create high
standards at old trafford
versus the other clubs you'd played at
what you know west ham and leeds etc
what was it they were doing
that kept those standards so high you
then also talk about going to qpr and
seeing low standards
and a certain type of negativity in the
changing room but what was it that they
were doing
or not doing because i want to create
high standards in my team and within my
life so
[Music]
good habits right every day good habits
whether it's punctuality again work
ethic
attention to detail intensity
when you're training on a training pitch
respecting each other
but all those things just they come
together and it creates a culture
at the club and i've been at west town
i've been at leeds
two very good clubs great clubs um
but they they didn't have that that
culture
which meant there was ability to win but
it starts from somewhere so alex
alex ferguson already won aberdeen so he
he knew how to create that culture
he went to maine united didn't have that
winning mentality at the time when he
went there
he created that and it all stems i
always think great leadership is
definitely what gives you an opportunity
to be successful and i
i noticed that throughout my career and
when you've you've set the foundations
and you've created that culture you
don't as a
as a leader have to be there every day
in that sense he was at a training
ground every day
how many times do you think he came into
our change room no idea
you wouldn't fill one hand really no
never came in a change room
in the training ground we're there every
day because he he knew that the culture
was set and then he had lieutenants
like me giggsy gary neville etc who were
then
filtering that down to any of the
younger players on the new signs
who didn't know the culture yet and then
then those players became the
the culture leaders and so it was it was
crazy man
and even for instance if he wasn't at
the training ground watching training
the training intensity might drop that
little
one percent two percent but you'd notice
it because the manager's not there
because he wasn't in the building
because he wasn't he didn't you didn't
feed him that aura that
he could be on his phone making bets
which he normally would be not
interested in training but his presence
alone was enough
and it just made when you look back and
you think this leadership is just key
and we're talking about investing
earlier yeah you know investing in the
the leader the people yeah the people
like it's so important i think and
i think every industry it's like that
football's where i'm from and that's
what it's like there but i see what
since i've retired
that's replicated in other industries
hundred percent isn't it funny as well
with culture
because you're right what you said there
is basically like what i've
something i used to think of social
change which is if a culture is strong
enough new people become like the
culture
if this culture is weak the culture
becomes like the new people 100
yeah i mean you couldn't have put it any
better
and i'll give you an example like
and again i didn't i didn't say it as
eloquently as that one husband football
but
berbatov came to maine united oh yeah
casual babs
he was wicked player beautiful touch
sexy looking footballer wicked
and before big champions league again my
fingers barcelona
he just weren't working hard enough for
the team and
i need i had the ball on this side of
the pitch and i needed him to come over
and help
he's just walking that and i ended up
just kicking the ball off and going
crazy
will you do get over wait when i get
over
then we'll do it and that's again that's
not our culture
at barcelona they play they wait that's
their culture that's not our culture
you want to play barcelona away go
barcelona here it's not the same
and if you don't buy into our culture
you won't be here long
and that's the way it was at united if
you came and you weren't in the co you
didn't buy into the culture
and immerse yourself in it and become
part of the fabric of the place
you weren't there more than a year or
two or you definitely wasn't an integral
member of that squad
and so it was definitely like you say
the culture is just
you have to become part of that culture
that you go into if it's strong enough
you see this in business it's crazy you
should do i feel like the perspective
you've got from being in that changing
room and understand because this it's
the same principles in business
it was the same at social chain and when
we grew the company and i realized that
i had to be like did you drive that a
hundred percent
and my like it got to the point where
what you've described is
people would understand who we were
without us having to say
and you'd have your disciples basically
introducing new people to the company
and going that's not a social chain
thing to do and we'd get that all the
time you'd say your people in office
okay and for example and the crazy the
other point i was going to say is
when the culture's that strong you it's
so easy to see when someone doesn't fit
well
they don't stand out we had you know
someone start on their first day at
social chain
and they're doing their initiation and
then they at the end of the initiation
they did two middle fingers and then
walked back to their desk
i said go get him we fired him he's gone
first day at social chain and then the
second the second instance where and it
sends a message to the team
because they i never knew it was
instinctive to me i said that's not the
same person get them out there was
another instance where we had a girl
join
who someone had hired and they told me
that she used to like bully people at
her last place and she had like a really
bad attitude and stuff and actually one
of the guys two of the guys in our team
said oh yeah we used to work with her
and she was a bit of a bully so
uh i i remember having the conversation
and i said you can't
like in a very very nice way i said she
she can't be here tomorrow
because that's not who we are here and
that my team were like but we need her
for this client we need her for this
project i was uncompromising i said no
we're not having her here
i don't care if we lose the job you know
i can't i say to my team
i can't have my name attached to a
culture like where we have people in it
who are like that so she's gone today
we'll figure it out if we lose the
client whatever and and it wasn't until
years later that you hear the team come
back to you and they say that moment
where you
you weren't willing to let that person
be needed in the team because they
weren't right for the culture
the team said that to me and that's
exactly what i hear from you i'm not
blowing to make up my own ass because i
didn't realize that you've recognised
that
it was it was it wasn't intentional it
was i just
wanted to enjoy my life in the company
to be a really really clear certain way
and i felt that that's what we needed to
do to succeed and in hindsight
and as you say it to me i'm like oh yeah
it was being unnegotiable right yeah and
that's what cerex ferguson was great at
if he saw something that was going to be
detrimental to the culture of the club
it was out that was non-negotiable even
if you needed them
so you look at roy keane yeah he's the
captain was the leader
the rule's been broken you're gone david
beckham
peak of his powers going out of a spice
girl
bringing all sorts of eyeballs to the
football club making an international
play
see you later yap stam the best center
half in the world at the time
said something about some of the players
in a book or something goodbye
rude van isteroy the best number nine in
the world at the time
goodbye like if you don't
fit the culture and you don't adhere to
the rules that are there
good night and we'll move on and we'll
build around other people
it's great it's like and where at the
time you sit there and you think bex you
can't sell beck's man
jesus who's going to come in like it's
like
number seven sells all the shirts like
everyone loves him everywhere we go
bex is like beatles like crazy
same with rudra and history you're
thinking how are we going to score goals
now man who's gonna squash the goals
rooney and and ronaldo are really young
still inexperienced
but he had that belief and that vision
just to like it was the culture over
everything
that's a big club no one's bigger than
the club it's so true man
and again like you say that reverberates
around a dressing room
right you better stay in line you better
just like live by the rules that are
here already
and stay part of that culture the hard
work the intensity
the respect and so that you
he would dig out the most experienced
player who hasn't even done anything and
you'd sit there and go what like
what are you shouting me for but he was
doing that to you because he knew you
could take it but the effect that i have
on the young ones or the other ones
which i mean so playing the mind games
man i love it it's good but you only
it's the mad thing is anyone you're in
it like you're saying you're talking
about social change you probably didn't
realize at the time
but when you sit back and you're outside
and you look back in that bubble you
think
[ __ ] man yeah that's why i didn't think
about it but that's why i've done it
yeah he's right yeah and i'm right now
or i'm wrong whatever it is
i mean that's how we think about like
certain things that fergie done you
think actually
he weren't just lucky man he actually
obviously was
plotting and planning that type of stuff
i am i wonder how much of that stuff was
intentional with him though in terms of
like
he i'm sure he wasn't going in the back
room and planning it it's just like
surely it's just like who he was
and i sometimes think you know you get
managers that will come into clubs and
they'll try and be like fergie
but you can't because you can't act for
that long and that consistently
because from what you're saying about
fergie it's like it's not like four
things he's doing it's a thousand
things he's doing consistently which
show his values
right and you can't act for 27 years
whatever it is across a thousand touch
points so it makes me feel like
how do you teach that like it was it
wasn't phil almost was like it wasn't
just instinctive to fergie
yeah i think it was instinctive he was
he's that's just him and don't forget
his experience as well would have played
a big part in that
he was at the club for like 26 or so
years 27 years so that's there's a
valuable amount of experience gained in
that time but
i always look at it like when i went
into the main united change room i sat
there
and just looked around and thought who's
good at what and let me just take
elements of
these people and add it to my my game
and my
preparation and my recovery and that's
what i've done ryan giggs was great at
recovery and
preparation done yoga and stuff like
that took that out of these
of his book roy keane leadership the way
he demanded
standards on a daily basis skulls these
best levels in training every day like
all them think i was just trying to
try to be like little peop parts of
different people
and then that allows hopefully for you
to grow into a better person a better
player etc
and i think that's the same with with
other industries and business since i've
retired it's like
you go in and try and be like someone
else you're gonna fail because you can't
be like the original but if you're
taking bits from elsewhere you might be
able to get beyond that
what you see as the best because you're
getting more you're taking more good
things from that person but then from
various other people to build maybe past
that and that's the way i try and
work with stuff now in my life there's
no one person i'm going to make that's
going to make me
the best at what i want to be but a
group
and taken from everywhere i've got a
better chance
people never talk about the things that
fergie was bad at well roy keane does
but
other than that i never hear people
saying and i've got his book somewhere
knocking around as well but
you never hear players talking about
some of the things where you think you
know i actually think he would have gone
been more successful if he didn't do
that thing
do you know if it's weird when people
die or when people retire
yeah you only remember the good stuff
really interesting you only think about
what they
their their existence before becomes
magnified and
you they're built up even bigger
sometimes
and fergie i think that's with him as
well because you just don't
you don't think i can think of instances
or or tactics you've got wrong
that's easy to find but but he'd always
make stuff right it was weird like um
even for instance the anti-racism stuff
and the situation was only sort of
documenting my brother yeah yeah yeah so
he went to a couple awards actually
yesterday
as well yeah so he um
the situation happened with him and john
terry
and i decided not to wear the next or
one of during that period
once a year all the teams are given
t-shirts show races and the red card or
kick racism out one of the campaigns
i wasn't willing to wear it because i
didn't believe that they
supported enough in the durian that's
that time so i said i'm not wearing it
he went crazy find me i was like
we end up winning the game which was
okay was lucky but the next day
i went into his office to just try and
explain to him why i hadn't won
the t-shirt and to be fair he said you
know what i understand
and i'm sorry for the way i reacted
but like stuff like that he might make a
mistake or he'd done that wrong but he'd
always rectify it always come back
around you get you back around somehow
and because he was just like a i don't
know he just
he knew how to deal with people he knew
how to treat people to get the best out
of him for what he's main goal was
how'd you teach that i don't know man
that's just i think that's something
that's inside
being able to deal with people read
people treat your team
do i mean so that they're running
through brick walls for you because you
come in a room and he'd say to you
you're not playing
and i'd be you'd want to scream and
you'd be like blood would be boiling
but you'd leave the room and you're
going to change room
and you're sitting in there gene
everyone up come on boys not sulking
because he's told you tuesday you're
playing because i need you for that game
you missed this one this is a big game
but you're going to play on tuesday
like normally you miss a game you you
want to go home and cry
about it i mean but he's managed to
build you back up and that's my
management
and in any industry that's that's like a
massive part of
again the culture but maintaining
sustaining a successful company of a
successful football club
you need to be able to build people pick
them up knock them down sometimes but be
able to keep them on that track with you
the contradiction i hear with within
like the story you recount of sir alex
versus the one i see in the newspapers
is you hear about the you know kicking
the football boot at beckham and this
guy who on this who on the sidelines
looks like he's out of control but what
you're describing
is like super self-aware yeah calculated
and he's actually
pretending to be out of control when he
needs to be we used to talk about all
the time sashimi and emmanuel vidic
and veda is a deep guy loves talking
about deep style gets deep into
stuff yeah he loves it like it's just a
matter he just loves like to
be on behind well how is he thinking
about that etc
just always talk about the manager and
like
you look back and say anything
everything he done was like calculated
like
the way he spoke on the tv blaming the
ref
so very rarely did he come on he didn't
come on tv and ever hammer none of the
players individually
we could lose a game and the referee
would be the [ __ ] the back page the next
day
but he's taking the heat of us he's
making us think about it's not us
we're not down in the doldrums it's
because of the referee that's dangerous
sometimes
you've got ideas about yourself
accountability but he makes there's
enough self accountability in the
building
but also the focus is over there now not
on us as a team so we go again
without that pressure oh they've lost
they're not as good anymore
but the referee was a reason so i mean
just like that's just like calculated
this is what i'm doing for the goodness
of my team and the betterment of my team
is good man
but people think anger and like you were
a player that wasn't wasn't afraid to
shout someone i heard you talking about
some of the players you gave a hard time
like anderson et cetera
what what is still yeah in the what's
that group
yeah really yeah what role does anger
play in leadership then because you see
it in football
but if if i were to start screaming at
people in the same
way that you did to i don't know berber
or whatever imagine if i just [ __ ]
kicked this table and said
what the [ __ ] the camera is not working
i would be i'd
be cancelled everyone would walk out
yeah i talk about this with my missus
quite a lot now we like
some of the stuff that we are when we're
talking about memories and whatnot and
how we spoke to someone so
or what's happening in the change room
would never happen in the office
because it's like you say it's like that
that relationship's over
it's gone too far whereas you could have
a fight at football and then you're
shaking hands and having a laugh in the
shower after
it's so different it's just a different
way of of working but
i think it's understanding people i
don't think you treat any two people the
same
in that sense like the blanket treatment
i don't think is the best way to treat a
team
because everyone's different everyone
takes advice differently everyone takes
criticism
differently so you've got to be able to
pick the right people to be able to
shout out to pick the right people
you've got to get an arm around
and and that's about as again a manager
a captain knowing that team knowing that
play that the players individually
all this coming into work and ghosting
everybody
is mad i don't get it i don't think you
can create that environment
for success if you're going to come in
and not know nobody
and that's another one of these so
alex's great traits is that he knew
everything about everyone
like if you're you're my granddad i was
in hospital once met my granddad
probably twice
in the uh players lounge after a game
knew my granddad's favorite drink brandy
the flower was turned up on my mom's
house which i mean it's like
that stuff there then people are coming
to work for you every day
after stuff like that it's little things
little details not any time out of your
diary really
his pa probably done it all yeah but his
name's at the bottom
it's like big it's little
little percentages like that are just a
key it's funny because
those little gestures help help you know
that he does care about you regardless
of what happens on the training ground
or in the match
fundamentally he cares about you and
wants you to do well and he's
you know what i mean you're not enemies
you are in so i think
by him saying that's the foundation it's
clear that having that as a foundation
allows him to put pressure on in the
right places it seems
yeah and he and you're not his mate yeah
ever well really no you're not you're
not he's mate i speak to him more now
than i did when i played
really because there was that line
and that he felt was always needed to be
there that we can have a little laugh
here and there but in the end of the day
i'm the manager
you guys do your thing there and have a
laugh etc but then there's that line you
don't go past
so but you just got it right and i think
that's down to experience as well
he would have learned that and a lot of
the guys so you say he was he was even
crazier before you guys came
when he was younger so he's obviously
work
and he worked out as well did the new
generation of player
couldn't take that
anger and that craziness
like the old generation like probably my
generation probably the last generation
that he could do that with
the next ones the younger ones the
andersons the nannies the ronaldo's etc
that's not the way that they would they
would they don't respond as well to that
type of
criticism and anger and aggressiveness
what was that anguish you ever saw him
too many times not too many times the
times when he kicked the boot at bex's
head was it was a
and you're in that crazy one yeah that
was crazy what happened
wouldn't it be great if we could make
looking after yourself your nutrition
and your health
cool again and i think this is
ultimately what hule has done in my life
and as i reflect on the last couple of
years that huel has been the easiest way
for me to become a better human and for
me being a better human meant having
better health
it meant better having mental health
more energy being more focused in my
work
and that's exactly what you've done for
me i hope we can make being healthier
cool especially as we emerge from this
lockdown where we've all realized
how important and foundational health is
and i think here's a great way to do
that try it out give it a go
everyone that has you know get lots of
photos on instagram and twitter of
people that have tried your
and started their huel journey brings a
little bit of joy to my heart because
not only
have you um are you a listener of the
podcast but also because i know that
you're on a journey to make your
your life and your health a lot better
and that if you know think about all the
sponsors i could have had to have a
sponsor that i genuinely believe
can help you change your life is a
privilege um that i'm glad to know
what was that angriest you ever saw him
too many times not too many times the
times when he kicked the boot at bex's
head was a
and you're in that crazy one yeah that
was crazy what happened
it was uh it was mad it was it was funny
man it was actually funny i gotta be
honest i can't lie
but the manager was he kicked the boot
in anger because he asked bex to do
something tactically that he didn't
carry out
and he booted and listen anybody i don't
care what ronaldo's playing today on
messi
wouldn't have hit the target the way hit
the target it was it was so clean
and the ball went in slow-mo like bang
and it hit him in the head and then
obviously beck scott was upset got up
and
i remember the gaffer was devastated you
could tell he could see when he looked
at him he sat down he was just slumped
almost
like he that's not what he'd done he
kicked the boot for he kicked it in
anger and it accidentally hit
backs in the head so he looked
devastated of it but
that was one that was i had a few
scrapes of him in terms of
i didn't agree with things that he'd
done a couple of times and i was
screaming and he didn't he didn't take
too well to it and
he lost it and he just would go purple
over the top of you and just spray you
screaming in front of you like that like
crazy
so but he was uh what it was it was
never personal which is that why you
respected it and you kind of it kind of
it kind of always was washed away
because
he you knew that deep down he wanted
just want you to do well
i mean it wasn't vindictive it wasn't
personal just do what i'm telling you to
do
you will win i heard you say that that
culture isn't there now
it's it's all friendly now on it
everyone's mates everyone's like for
instance
everyone's mates and commenting on each
other's posts on social media
so you're more attached to someone
you're more involved with someone
whereas before i would only see certain
players twice a year
home and away so i've got no attachment
to you so for to me have a bit of venom
or to go at you a little bit was normal
and i've got
no qualms about doing that because i
ain't going to see you again don't care
i might see you at england camp or
something like that but i don't i slack
three or four times a year so we're
colleagues exactly
we're not really matey whereas now in
the tunnel they're all shaking cuddling
yeah man comment on your post you have a
day
it's very different i'm not saying it's
bad but it's just different is it bad
so i don't know it's just like it's it's
different so going into
into battle into a game
i've got no emotional ties or no social
media ties to anybody
so i can there seemed to be that bit
more it
i don't know if there's more passion
before to now but it seemed to be like
there was yeah
because i think all of this stuff is
social media makes it a bit more fluffy
and people are hugging and shaking hands
and whatnot
now because they've spoken or had a
message or liked a post
very different me my my friends at my
manchester united chat when uh
one of the observations that we have all
the time is like why is why is everyone
been so nice to each other and
you i remember last week there was a
tweet went out from one of the
united um press people and it was just a
quote something harry mcguire had said
on the field
and he basically screamed i don't know
someone else yeah i need to like get
[ __ ] back in line or whatever
it's like trending on twitter yeah yeah
because i don't see it because you don't
see it anymore
and then and then also i you know love
him love him or whatever but
watching uh ollie fist bump the managers
with a smile on his face
we've been grown up as united fans with
us we would
fergie would look [ __ ] furious to
even have to look at the
opposing manager and and it just feels
different now and then we look at where
we are and how we're performing in the
big games and we're not winning like we
used to
and we're all saying oh that you know
we're coming like arsenal or something
but we everyone always like clings on to
the history in it and
that's that's the problem as a football
fan i'm the same like you just want it
to be like it was before
please right but it's never going to be
the same
it may be a successful or even more
successful one day but it will never be
the same
so our expectation then we'll sometimes
just have to change a little bit but
yeah i mean again like it was coming in
anyway because like for instance i
remember joe rpk hugging
and fist pumping et cetera in the tunnel
with fabregas
and we were mad rivals we've asked on
that point like pizzagate and all that
stuff
and he got hammered after that pk in our
change room are you doing
before a game you're sitting in a chat a
lot or or without make fun of him a
little bit there's two different ways
you
ridicule and get someone in line either
humor or being firm
and you probably got both but it was it
was that was a
you could sense a change coming it was
coming and obviously social media i
think has accelerated that definitely
ed woodward as well there's a lot of
controversy surrounding him at the
moment again because for better for work
no not yet no yeah when the when uh
when we can travel a little bit more
we'll uh i think he'll he'll come on but
um
i remember hearing the story about the
exit treatment that you had with him
and i wondered if you were still
somewhat bitter about that i heard you
know
one of your last games at the club and
he comes into the training room and
tells you that you're you're not going
to be playing for the club anymore you
didn't get your send off
yeah of course i think there's no
there's nothing that anyone could tell
me that wouldn't
make me feel that was the wrong way
would fergie have done that no thank you
zero no
you'd have told me before the end of the
season because you know what it mean but
the difference is that fergie was a
footballer
and he knows what it means he knows what
it is
to be able to say thank you for your
support etc
just have that little runway to ascend
off now listen i understand not
everybody can have it that way but if
you've got
if you know and you've got the
opportunity to give someone the best
possible route out of a situation
you give it to them and my situation i
think it was you could see down the line
from
month a month two months before that
that you knew what was gonna happen with
me
so give me the opportunity to have the
best possible send off given the time
given the relationship that i built with
the club
so that was my my only discrepancy of
the whole way it worked out because it
wasn't like oh actually a knee-jerk
situation knee-jerk decision so but i
think listen
ed knows how i feel about it but we've
moved on past that i'll speak to him on
the phone
about various different things anywhere
we meet up sometimes so it's cool
but those small moments that's an
isolated incident
but that's that isolated incident is
attached to a wider philosophy
in the same way that fergie had this
like wider philosophy of like you know
sending your
your granddad the the flowers and that's
a tattoo wider philosophy so although
that's just one instance
i think the risk that i would see and
when i hear things like that i think
well
that same philosophy of like not really
caring being that empathetic
has got to be popping up in other places
right like oh 100
and that again we've said culture about
10 times already in this
conversation yeah but that's that's
part of a culture yeah like
there has to be like you say compassion
empathy
respect as a family right like that's
what the club was
and that was the way i used to explain
man united i left leeds which was like a
family
a small i say this is a smaller version
without obviously the success but a
smaller version in terms of the people
here
been here for 30 years 40 years 20 years
my dad used to work here my mom used to
work here that's a family club
man united was that when i was there
my fear is that it becomes something
else some of the waiting stuff i had a
box at my united mm-hmm
and it's funny this is a staggering
thing but for me because you don't think
of you know
the waiting staff in the box are gonna
notice a cultural shift at the club
right but they would tell me they they
said to me you know when fergie and
david gill were here
it was different how did it touch the
waiting staff that served me because
they know
all their names yes that's what they
said to me they know all their names
they had a relationship david gilman had
a relationship with the the person
giving me a steak
and it and i just thought that was
staggering that this you know
anything like how strong the culture
must be and how important it must be for
the waiter
giving me you know some chips to be like
it's different now the dinner lady at
the training ground i actually spoke to
her on the way here funny that's just me
a voice note but it didn't lady carroll
she could have been with director
manager or david gill
like first name terms
banter that had been spread over a
number of years so they could go back
and have a proper
back and forth he knew the name of the
groundsman
but it was like and and if if
if i'm at man united now that is part
where i'm going
that that has to be recreated bring that
back
because that's a strength like i said
before about strength in numbers
that's the foundation of the football
club people come in that place and think
oh my god
they're all made united here they're all
feel part of it
that that creates does that start with
fergie and david at the top
yeah i think it has to and that's why i
look back on things like that and like
you you speak to any of the people that
work there that was
a big part of it because everyone thinks
it's the is the first eleven
the the team the squad the first team
that play
that's the main united it's not it's the
fans
and it's all the people that work behind
the scenes to enable that first level
and that team that squad to go out there
and perform
if there's people out around that aren't
working that's what the manager used to
say
all these people the kit man the physio
nutritionist the dinner lady etc these
lot help you enable you to be successful
so don't forget that i mean and all
those people have an expectation of the
performance and like the they all become
winners like as a united fan growing up
i was like we win yeah 100 and and you
know
as a fan i was like you know we come and
we win and then at some point when
fergie left i'm like i'm not sure really
what happens
sometimes yeah yeah and you know that
crazy thing fergie had in the last
couple of minutes of every game where
you thought we're gonna [ __ ] win this
there's only two minutes left
but somehow but you know like the things
i just mentioned there about the club as
well that does
that is a byproduct of success as well
it that becomes easier
it's like a self-fulfilling yeah right
exactly when you're winning
it's like everything when you're
successful and you're winning
everything's kind of run smoothly
doesn't it
yeah and then obviously when things
start to go a little bit wrong you see
so many more bumps in a row so many more
splinter groups come out and start
pointing the finger etc so
i just think that it's keeping it
getting that culture right and getting
the people who feel part of the club
and then you win with that as well
there's no better
kind of then you've got to defend it
right you've got to defend the culture
again because the culture is the thing
that made you win
yeah and so you might get some big
people getting too big for their boots
or whatever or distracted
and then fergie's just got this great
reputation of bit defending that culture
as the most important thing and are you
that's people say why did he win how did
he win for 20 odd years no one else has
managed to do that in the modern era
and it's just that but it's it's i
always put it down to as well things
like
dedication desire but he was always the
first in a training ground
i tried to try and beat him to get a
training ground sometimes take my kids
to school and get there like
we used to start like half nine you have
to be in a half nine
i used to get in sometimes at eight
o'clock and these cars there already
last to leave most of the time uh yes
that's again that goes back to the point
of saying about
showing your kids rather than telling
them be early be it
just be there you're there then they
know he's always there
you can't be late why are you late the
manager says he's been 26 years
and he's early every day and you're not
he's obviously prepping like you don't
do your prep work in the gym why
i remember i keem pulled a meeting
called a meeting because he thought the
young players weren't
doing the extras and why are you going
home before
an ex that experienced player there that
we said to them yeah when you're
you're in the start of the ladder what's
we called an actual meeting
yeah so that he just said to the lads
listen guys like after training all
coming in or before training all come in
a change room
and everyone sat down and he's like
listen i've got to say it because i'm
seeing it every day and it ain't good
for the club
some of you young boys i'm seeing you
and some even the older the players are
a little bit older than that but
how can you be going home before him
he's doing extras working outside or he
goes in the gym or before training i see
sansa doing that and you're just messing
about in
in the uh canteen or something like that
it's valuable time don't miss it
short career things like that but that's
again
the manager allowing people to manage a
change room and that's how it was there
you had people that managed to change
room
and you had the manager that oversaw it
all what was the difference between some
players that arrive at manchester united
and ultimately end up reaching their
potential and then some
that don't and there's been a lot of you
know well written about players that
never reached their potential
is was there a commonality that you saw
that made it because i'm like gary
neville i'm like he wasn't the most
i like the guy he's actually managed me
once in this charity game
like the guy but he didn't strike me as
the most
naturally talented player at work but he
felt yeah
and then work dedication attention to
detail
application on a daily basis like this
is the thing a lot of people think i've
worked hard for two weeks and i've got i
haven't i haven't got any rewards out of
it
the manager's still not playing me i'll
give up no
that's got to be we're talking before a
lifestyle hard work every day is a
lifestyle
that should be like the standard that's
the standard that is here
and you've got to be at that every day
there's none of this taking your foot
off the pedal
because it's difficult carlos carroll
said to me you can't just switch it on
and off
like that mentality that intensity the
dedication the hard work on a daily but
you can't just go
i work hard on monday to wednesday
thursday friday i'll just chill and then
saturday
switch it on again habits
lifestyle all the time like that so when
it comes to match time it's not a big
shift
because your body can't do it that your
mind can't deal with that if it's
normalized
this is normal on a saturday three
o'clock sixty thousand people screaming
100 million people around the world
that's not pressure do this every day
one of the like alienating things when
people might hear you talk and they
think oh well
almost intimidating it's like well rio's
mentality is just so
[ __ ] like disciplined and you know
he's got it now and
i did listen i weren't perfect this is
what i was gonna ask tell me about tell
me how you weren't perfect yeah i went
perfect it took me a long time to start
understanding like your body
understanding your mindset and my state
of mind had to be
a tip-top condition both mentally and
physically on a
game day and west ham i didn't have it
leads i didn't have it because i was
inconsistent
i was really i trained hard but then i'd
be going out every
every other night i'd go out four or
five times a week parties
pissed like west ham i don't remember a
lot of results or
certain things when people say what
about that game when you
i actually can't remember i was that i
used to be out and get
pissed so often and then i got to
maintain and i just
was surrounded by people that had won
and i was desperate to win
so what do you do to win i'm gonna copy
of him him him like we spoke about
before and then you become part of that
and then you realize that none of these
lot are going out all the time
so if i'm gonna go out and continue that
lifestyle i had before
my levels are obviously always going to
be a bit below these guys because you
can't
sustain that you're always working from
a less
from a lower standpoint so i changed
that and
listen i still made mistakes but my
intentions
and my desire was to always be as good
as i could be i wanted to be better than
veda
vidic john terry sol campbell i need to
be the best when people talk about the
best center back i need to be the first
name on their lips so what
what can i do i was not obsessed with it
you know i mean and
why the lads wouldn't have probably
known how
obsessed i was with it because i would
never show that really but inside
the thought that someone thought that
someone else is a better center back
than me used to
like it would eat away at me why
because i just pride ego we all got egos
you want to be the best
and i was never ashamed myself to be to
feel like that i'll say that that
i didn't say it at the time because it
etiquette it's not the thing to do in
american sports they do it they talk
like that because i wish we was more
because naturally i'm that type of
person i would say it i think i'm the
best on it
so i don't care that i would say now i
thought i was the best centerback
but i was always i just wanted to be the
best whether i was or not
it's for other people to decide but i
was that was my always my intention
you and vidic partnership a lot of my
friends at the moment that's where i've
been
i'm a big fan of harry maguire and uh
what he does
mainly because i from what i hear he's
one of the only leaders in the back line
like you know always shouting what was
it that made you and vidic so successful
as a partnership because
my friends they'll do anything to have
you guys back
what was it about you two because you're
known as
in my opinion the best centre-back
partnership we've ever had that's why
i'm here because i knew you'd say that i
appreciate that man don't know man
he had attributes that just complimented
mine and vice versa
he was a he wanted to go and attack
every ball okay when the ball got kicked
in the skies
he just saw one thing and that was the
ball
and he was better at that than me okay
but
i read stuff and would clean up around
all of that and
was more of i don't know i read the game
probably a little bit different to him
and
but at the same time i was capable of
going up and winning the ball and then
he'd do that with me
whether he was as good at me at cleaning
up on that for other people to decide
but like
i i don't know it was just we just
compliment each other and what it was
there was a pride about
our defendant us too so you see a lot of
people it's like me
i'm the best i want to be the best which
is true but the overriding factor of me
wanting to be the best is that we don't
concede and we're a partnership
i'm going to be i've got your back and
that's what you just say before a game
video you go up i'm behind you don't
worry when i got you're behind me yeah
that's all it was all the time you
challenge i'm behind you don't worry
just go for the ball go for the man take
the man and the ball
i'm here if it goes wrong and is that
having that sense of security for each
other
there was a chant of vidiq's chat about
him being a bit of a murderer yeah yeah
crazy how did he how did he feel about
that and like yeah he's quite an
unassuming guy he's really like he's not
really taken
or by anything right did they say that
about me oh cool it's good
not bad not bad and then carries on with
laughs like he's really just
chilled man he's so different to what
he's like if he's just a chill guy
he's intense guy to be fair intense
and some players may have found him at
times quite moody at times and just
really like in with what he's doing
because he's so intense
and he would really like to think about
a lot of stuff and probably overthink
certain situations but i got on really
well with him he's one of my
my closest guys at maine united when i
was there
from now yeah i talked to him now on the
texts and stuff he's living in milan at
the moment
yeah one of the things that um has
happened since your playing days is
there's been a huge rise in the
conversation around mental health
wasn't a conversation back then really
um even even for me
growing up that didn't know what it
meant i'll be completely honest i
thought mental health was
um someone goes crazy psychiatrist yeah
yeah just a stray jacket or something
that's what i we always thought it was
that's all
the depiction of someone that's lost
their mind and
um we've come to learn about it in a
much different way now we view it as a
sort of intrinsic part of health but
everyone has
mental health and it it can sit on some
kind of spectrum right
based on what happens um i was wondering
back then like the players in that
dressing room
they had mental health and they had
mental health issues and stuff then but
i'm guessing it was never addressed it
was never talked about or
i i've done a documentary on bbc about
like grief and bereavement and stuff and
obviously mental health is a huge part
of that
and i got to understand mental health
through that journey of making a
documentary
and understanding that when i played
again mental health was not a thing at
all
and it was never considered there was no
compassion and if you acknowledged your
mental health and started to
talk about it as i have problems or an
issue he was then seen as a weak link
whether it was spoke about or not he was
there that would be the case that would
be how you see that whole situation
and so no one then talks about it
through fear of being called the weak
link
um and i look back now and think yeah
definitely if we had been
more open enough we had today's
thought process about mental health
would have got more out of certain
players definitely really um
yeah because louis sahar for instance
what a player yeah unbelievable
footballer had injuries
but along with the injuries that brought
a mental health
problem for him and
like a bit depressed and down and
whatnot because he felt was letting
everyone down that's what you feel when
you're injured you feel you're letting
your teammates down and it's hard to
deal with sometimes especially if you
just keep getting little injuries and
you come back you go again you come back
and people start always always injured
mentally is not strong is he don't fancy
it
and you as a player you know them
conversations are going on so you start
thinking about that and when people see
you think he's always
he's doubts me anyway and so that mental
warfare that goes on
it could be sorted out through
conversation not
acknowledging certain things but you're
taught in a macho dressing room
that talking is seen as a weakness back
then
i think there's big changes now like you
say the narrative now is very different
so you'd like to think it's changing and
clubs are more aware of that
i am i remember watching that
documentary remember i think i remember
where i was when i watched it because
it really really hit me um and like
there's
i don't watch a lot of tv but also i am
uh it's quite hard
to make something impact me but because
you were so vulnerable
as someone that i you know grew up
watching as a kid and you were able to
to be emotional
it it yeah it really it hits it hits you
in a completely different way
tell me about your thought process why
you wanted to do that because i'm
betting it wasn't easy right
no it was it was it was crazy it was
hard man but it was
it was mainly for my kids if i'm honest
and for everyone else because i wanted
my
obviously my kids lost they lost their
mum so
again it's like most about the same
point you can't just keep telling them
sometimes it'd be nice to have something
you can just show them and that speaks
for itself
and it's visual as well and so they get
a clear idea of
where we're all at where we was at and
how we've got to this point of hopefully
a little bit of healing and on that
journey
we realized actually we're going to help
a lot of people here
so many more than just selfishly our own
family
so it became like a real
real i'm a positive journey for us in
that sense of of working out what it
means to talk
to communicate your feelings how much
benefit that is to you as an individual
but also other people
um working on relationships and how
it can change your relationship when you
are talking
and and so again it was a difficult
journey because
you've got to open up like you say show
that vulnerable side to you and
and again that's probably again what
that's how we started the conversation i
wasn't scared to do that
it was a difficult situation but i
weren't scared of doing that because i
knew
at the end of the day my kids are going
to benefit from this and whatever that
however this journey goes
i'm willing to to be a part of it for
that for that one reason
and then when it was when it when it was
um finished and we when i bathed her in
the environment great part of it is that
you walk down the street or you go down
the island sainsbury's or where tesco
wherever it is and
an old age lady or a man come up to you
you know what
the tear in the eye or something like
that and the throat's all
croaky and i watched your program i've
never spoken before really
you helped me that stuff that's the the
reward that you get from something like
that that i didn't anticipate
and you one of the things you you said
when i was you know
hearing you talk about mental health and
really the i guess the crux of the
documentary is that the healing comes
from
opening up and communicating um and in
fact you might never get over
what happened and you don't necessarily
need to but it's like when you take it
out from the
the closet in the back you know back
part of your mind
because you were talking about
compartmentalizing it yeah a lot and
that was how you
you were handling it at first and you
know i think a lot of the data shows
that when you try and compartmentalize
grief or never
but it comes at you in other ways right
and it jumps in yeah
you get bad habits you you fall into
holes that you never knew were ever
possible to go down
and then to get back out of them is it
becomes it like almost an impossible
journey so
it was it was and that's how i probably
would have been with a lot of stuff in
my life before you just compartmentalize
it you put it over there you don't think
about it but you've never dealt with it
you've never got that situation out and
unpacked it
and then used it to bring some sort of
positivity to your life
people don't want to open it though no
because it's scary yeah vulnerable
and today i'd rather just get through
today then unpack that stuff
yeah and have to go through that stuff i
have to go through them feelings their
emotions
have to have that hurt a little bit
again but i've
we've said it to the kids all the time
like like sometimes crying is such a
a relief sometimes and the weight of it
that goes off your shoulder sometimes
when you you do
release that emotion is like it's crazy
you can't really put it into words what
it feels like at times
that you've had that then moments where
you felt really down or you're missing
someone
and then you have a little bit of
emotional time on your own or with
friends or with family or whatever it is
and then you there's a smile immediately
comes sometimes out of the back of it
because you feel actually i actually
feel better now i knew that you move on
you carry on with your day but
it is it's a that type of situation that
we've kind of been through
it's never gone but you learn how to
deal with things that bit better
all the time what are some of the sort
of techniques you use to try when you do
feel
down or you feel like you know there's
something bugging playing on your mind
and stuff and you might be getting
anxious about something is there
anything that you've learned
from your experiences that helps you um
in those moments
like outside of talking or strategies or
is there
one of the things that i was um i've
started doing this that might sound
really strange is
when i so what will happen with me is
something will be playing on my mind and
i try and tell myself how you can deal
with that you're fine
whatever and then three hours later in
the shower and you're still thinking
about it
and i know that it's gonna harm me if i
don't like address it so i will
literally that sounds like [ __ ]
bunkers first time i've ever said this i
literally say it out loud
and i have this like weird conversation
with myself where i say steve like
you're feeling us go literally you're
feeling like this because of this and
this
and yeah it's making you feel a bit like
you know it's making you feel a bit bad
at the moment or whatever
um but but then i try and reason with
myself as if i'm talking to someone else
and it has really helped me um it's but
it makes me feel like a nutter
yeah i understand what you're saying but
you know
unfortunately i've got an unbelievable
wife who i can talk to
like communication is a massive part and
where i've improved in my life hundred
percent so i
that conversation you're having there
i'll have with my wife
and i'm lucky how she helped you with
that oh massively
i don't probably tell her enough but
like what she's brought to my life
in terms of being able to open up to
communicate not only with her
but with my kids now i speak to my kids
in a different way now in terms of
because i know communicating and letting
them show their feelings
trying to just always if there's a
situation that's
prince's mother's day just come
obviously my house is quite i said my
mum passed away and
the babies their mum passed away as well
so
mother's day is and then kate's a new
mum
so there's so many dynamics in the house
and that one day the emotional
kind of energy in the house on that day
is like through the roof
and so to manage that and to
make it a a day where everybody's
enjoying it and happy
and celebrating mother's day is that's a
task in itself
but talking to the kids we had a
conversation on mother's day at the
table was eating food and stuff and it
was like
um my little boy was like oh like
i said to him like you don't post
anything on on mother's day do you
and he's not an emotional poster anyway
he just posts about what he likes like
football and stuff
and and whatever so he's like yeah i was
actually thinking of doing it this this
um
this mother's day but like obviously
because like
i wasn't sure what to what to do like
with kate and mum so i
didn't know what to do and it was like
hate almost like off you started crying
really because like i don't want you to
feel like that post what you feel don't
worry about no one else
just post what you feel because no one
can tell you what you feel
and you're not going to disappoint
anybody do what you feel
which i mean and it's like those
conversations i would never have had
with my kids
before because i just wasn't i wasn't in
that in that
in that zone i was always very like
again
compartmentalized very closed closed but
emotionally
zero coming out really like but that was
condition because my dad was like that
all right
so and we talk about that in the dark as
well like my dad was very very
he wasn't open with his feelings really
and old school very
old school west indian man so
that follows through generations so
see talking is and communicating with
with the kids and kate and
she's the one who's really brought that
since i've met her in that sense and i
i'd never be able to thank her enough
for that
just that one element let alone the
other stuff that she's brought to the
table
you just you don't you don't talk to her
and you think you might not talk to her
enough though
i don't tell her enough maybe how would
you how um
i'll tell everyone else like all my
mates know that she's been unbelievable
for us she's like
oh you don't tell her i probably don't
tell her enough sometimes
right and that would sometimes have
conversations and she and i'll go yeah
but i told someone so like
you was like you done this oh
you told them before me right which is
crazy really isn't it
you should really just tell that person
why don't you
i don't know it's the old me still about
really probably yeah yeah
probably the old me still about i don't
know and sometimes a bit like shy
not shall i be embarrassed maybe i don't
know to say that yeah but it's
yeah i should i will
i will i'll send you the clip you can
just let the clip
get it she'll see this on it she's going
why didn't you just tell me like
yeah that's true that's incredible um
as a guy that's single me mm-hmm and has
struggled for very thinking
[Music]
yeah no not you so yeah as a guy that's
single and struggled
over the years to to get into a
relationship because i've been busy well
this is what the [ __ ] i tell myself
is commitment issues is it well well my
parents so there's there's a slight
issue from my childhood where like my
mum and dad used to scream each other
all the time so i just learned that
relationships were like prison because
my dad would sit there passively my
mum's screaming in his face
and i would i just learned that as a man
when you get a relationship
you're in prison and your freedom's gone
and i'm so i'm someone that alec
really doesn't want to give up my
freedom and whenever i get
close to that commitment i feel the fear
which comes clearly comes from my
childhood but what are the things that
you you know
as a guy that is super successful over
the last you know a couple of decades
and now he's running businesses and
chasing a bunch of other ambitions that
you have what are some of the things
you've learned about how to have a
successful relationship as a
busy guy one of them's communication i
guess but yeah communication but i think
time management is massive as well
really
and yeah yeah time management like and
kate's helped with that as well like
managing your diary like i'm busy i've
got a lot of stuff running out that i
enjoy and i'm one of them passionate
about which is key
but i'm as passionate if not more about
my family as well
so managing that diary to make sure
you've got quality time and you've got
enough time with your family but also
you know you're going to work is so
key but also the time when you're there
be there
okay i mean i speak to a lot of guys who
are managers a lot my friends are
managers now
and that's why i'll never go into
management i don't think because
as a football manager you have to be
you have to live it breathe it every
minute like
that's the same in business but is it i
don't know if with football i just find
there's a different
it's quite different that we're talking
about the way that people talk to each
other at football it's different to an
office
there's elements that are probably
different as manager i feel but
as a football manager you're at home
you're having sunday dinner with your
family but you're not there
yeah you're thinking about logistics
you're thinking about
the nutritionist does he sort things out
with the players that players are gonna
be fit this week or not and he didn't
fit
that player just got injured at a week
and i can't believe it's thinking about
how am i going to replace him
for what formation am i going to play
the other team have got a formation they
played different at the weekend
i need to watch that video i need to
watch that for that 90 minutes they
played two games last week different i
gotta watch them games as well
that's without thinking about like doing
your team talk and doing
your tactics on a training pitch and
setting up your training sessions for
the week
without thinking about any and so when
you're at home you're not home you're
not there really
you're physically there but mentally
you're not there you might as well not
be there
so i never i never wanted to get in that
position especially given what we've
been through so
um i definitely i just kind of wrote
that off as being something i'll do
because of that reason
and we were talking again before we
start recording about your
real deep uh desire to make sure that
football isn't the thing that you're
you become known for right and i uh
i i find that that fascinating but like
um it's a big mountain to climb right
like
to get known for some of the things
you're doing now you're heavily involved
in business you're investing you've got
five
uh what are these what we talked about
focus as well at the start of your
journey deciding that it wasn't going to
be gymnastics it wasn't going to be bad
you know ballet it was going to be
football yeah what is it now
so that's what i mean that situation
that scenario is almost replicating
itself now
i'm in that space right now so when my
dad said to me what do you want to do
make a choice i've retired
and the last four or five years i've
been working out what i'm going to do
i'm trying this i'm trying that i'm not
scared to try this i'm not going to try
that
if it doesn't work it doesn't work but
then i know i'm not i'm not that's not
for me
and i'm kind of getting to a place now
where i'm starting to drill down and
focus on a
couple of different spheres what are
they saying to go down so
the the the five youtube channel yeah
and creating that football hub that
football place to be
my foundation which goes into
communities and gets kids that from
disadvantaged backgrounds gives them
the opportunity to get an education and
then the opportunity
to get into work through the
relationships with a few of the
commercial companies that i've
built relationships with over the years
um
what else there's the management company
football management company so we've got
managers and players
past and present that we managed for
about 85 95 players
um which is that's one of my passions
and i get to mentor players within that
which is
the best bit for me where so for
instance
england player michael keane ben godfrey
mason holgate the murphy twins
uh even chris wilder i'll speak to as
well but i get to mentor these players
nice who i can have some sort of effect
given the experience that i've gained
over the years
so to have played that little role in a
lot of these guys and i do that with the
premier league players and nationals
two players that are from lower leagues
or just starting on the journey who
haven't made it yet
um we were 17 18 years old so they i get
great kicks out of stuff like that as
well
do you know which path you're gonna take
i don't know i'd love to be able to do
all
yeah but i know it's not possible to be
super successful
spreading yourself in like that so i
will
eventually go this is me it's funny
because when i when i speak to you and
i've spoken to you and obviously all my
punditry stuff
of course yeah yeah which is actually
given yeah when i speak to you when i
spoke to you last time when we met a
couple out then a year or two again we
were standing in the sea for about 35
about an hour i think i think we're
talking remember you remember that in
dubai standing
oh yeah i was talking about the other
time yeah where like i came i came to
like
roughly where you live you came to
social chain one time yeah yeah yeah i
came to where you lived and then i
forgot the dubai time yeah yeah but
every single time
when when i speak you look at me in a
certain way and i can see it you're like
listening very and then you start asking
questions around certain things
and you're very very very very curious
and i've noticed this i feel it when i
start talking you go
you look at me like this um does the
same thing yeah yeah
so you're you're a novel you do a lot of
stuff
you're you're doing this you've got a
book coming out you're investing you
know
you've sold it you've been a part of a
company that was valued at 200 plus
million pounds
like you're doing so much stuff there's
a theater show you're doing or whatever
you
mentioned before so there's so much
stuff that you're doing you're spinning
plates
i find that exciting how the [ __ ] are
you doing that
i want to know i don't want to know like
sometimes it's not even about what
you're doing for me
it's how you're doing it mm-hmm i mean
like
even a podcast
i'm just like all little things like
that i love it so i don't know
i'm i'll just i've got a curious mind in
that sense definitely
when i was young i was curious to find
out what nightclubs look like inside
i mean that's all i wanted to do was
find out i want to get in nightclubs
that's what i don't know west ham yeah
so i mean you just a young player
just coming up in primary get invited to
everything i was curious
i mean but that's for the wrong reasons
you've not you've lived this crazy life
right that you've lived a life that
me as a young kid growing up in devon
and plymouth i was you know watching my
little
tiny little one foot tv with my brothers
my three brothers sat there
you know that was the life that i wanted
to lead and you've gone through that
journey you've you've now come out the
other end and you're doing all this
other crazy stuff
as you look back on the cut span of your
career
you must now know that there's certain
fundamental things that matter
and a lot of [ __ ] that doesn't what are
the things that matter
i used fiverr once a month before they
became a sponsor on this podcast
and since they've become a sponsor on
this podcast and i've delved into what
the site does and how all the services
work and the vast array of things that
you can achieve on fiverr using
freelancers around the world
i swear on this dog's life pablo my dog
here who sat on my lap if you can't see
i swear in his life that i've used
fiverr
at least once a week for the last three
months we've built so
many websites we've designed so many
decks we've had
video clips edited we've had subtitles
produced
if you haven't checked out fiverr before
hit the link in the bio
fiverr.com ceo go to the website check
it out
and every single time i do this podcast
one person who dm's me with a service
from fiverr that they need doing for
their business
for their podcast for whatever project
they're working on i will pay
for that service to be done for you so
find a service on fiverr that you want
done
send me a message and one person every
week will have that service paid for by
me
you must now know that there's certain
fundamental things that matter
and a lot of [ __ ] that doesn't what are
the things that matter
because i'm a little bit earlier on so
i'm still figuring out some of these
things i'm like oh look money this is
interesting you know like
health man really health is the
it's the biggest the biggest it's the
biggest thing
because when you're healthy you're so
happy we spoke about before
like confidence it breeds how happy you
are
and it energizes you but if you're not
healthy
it can be devastating so health is a
massive thing which i probably i didn't
consider for many years
probably till we hit that bad patch in
our lives
um i took it for granted
pandemic now has been another pandemic
is an absolute like if you wasn't awake
then you are woken now
to health and what does that mean for
you in terms of staying healthy now
well we spoke about it before in terms
of of
like what does health mean to it is
passing it on to the next generation of
kids
my own kids first and foremost but then
like to to kids to understand that
going to the gym and just like in and
out
little fads here and there health kicks
here and there isn't at me
yeah you're talking about me it's not a
lifestyle yeah
yeah like and we've got friends that we
both know who are like that as well
and you've been like that before it's
just it's not
yeah it's not the way it's not healthy
for starters
but up here it just leaves you you're
always
chasing something whereas when you get
consistency
with your lifestyle and health and your
healthy lifestyle
there's like almost like a an excel like
oh
actually i get it now and it becomes
it's not it's not a drain on your life
it becomes something that adds value to
your life in the end and i think that's
something to try and transfer that over
to this next generation of
kids is i think a key way and this
pandemic isn't
something i think can accelerate that
and it will accelerate that because
like i said i'm on the board at the gym
group now and
trying to get people to understand and
get back into coming into gyms is a
massive push it's a massive it's a key
part and how do you do that because it's
not only the importance of a spreadsheet
it's actually you're doing something
that's going to help people now
and prevent illnesses from being healthy
a lot of the time
and help their mental health which
people yeah yeah that's what i'm saying
people think it's just physical
yeah it's not like i'll go in a gym in
that hour is unbelievable
three four times a week because you're
on your own
or with a a partner or a pt whatever it
is
and some of your best ideas or best
flushing of things
is there all my ideas right because
you're having that time alone and you're
getting to sit and not think about
anything else but
your reps or whatever it is and then
actually bang something hits you
[ __ ] that's kind of for later last one
i'll go back to that it's good
it's unbelievable it unlocks so much it
does yeah
it's my i said i'm sorry every day at
9pm every single day without fail
um i go to the gym and regardless of how
busy i am here which is always too busy
every day the team say they know that at
certain time i get up and i go to the
gym every single day without fail
and it's and it's you see it as okay
what i'm trying to get muscles it's like
no
that's where i think of ideas so health
and i'm really i'm really happy that you
said that because
um i've had that revelation in the last
year and i think making so cool
thank you making health cool again would
um help more parts of society than we
realize
especially guys that are looking for a
sense of purpose in their life you know
yeah definitely i think that
and it's again this that's the pandemic
as well
maybe created a lot more health
conscious people and
it's just the ways in which they're
going to work out now is is going to be
key
and even my kids are the same like i was
i say to him i don't want to have to
come home and tell you to work out
you should want to work out just do it
and then sometimes i might be driving
somewhere
and all of a sudden one of the boys or
my little girl they're running somewhere
that's like for me that's a success like
something that's that's
that's what i want to see do you mean
because i'm not forcing them to do it
if they're doing it off their own back
now this could be like their lifestyle
for the rest of their life that they're
healthy living healthy understand what
it means so
and my two boys want to be footballers
as well so it's important for them to be
physically active as a dad that was a
football legend what do you do
to help a son that wants to be a
football player get there
pray i'll pray every night and just say
please man let my kids be players like
every other parent um
i'd give everything for them to play
football and be like top players
seriously man but if they don't this is
what i always say to them but there
ain't pressure
if you don't make it i don't care it's
life i would love it to be
if you don't make it it's fine you do
something else
one unfortunately is a centre-back like
me okay at the moment why unfortunately
because then he'll be judged against me
more if he played a different position
like my other goalkeeper my other one's
a goalkeeper
okay so no one's gonna say oh he's not
not as good as rio because he's a
goalkeeper you know what i mean so
um but yeah but they're both they're
both playing now they're both
clubs so they're happy that when the
biggest thing they're enjoying it which
is great
so that's a basic answer but it's so
true i mean they're doing something that
they enjoy that they want to get up out
of bed every day for
and that's all you want and it goes back
to the same thing when you're there
you better be working don't want this
like if the manager comes to me and
they're doing the appraisal of your
performances the last
two months i do every quarter they come
back and tell me that you don't work
hard enough
you ain't going because you're just
embarrassing for yourself to hear that
but do you is there anything that you
can do can you like call someone to be
like give my kid a chance and
because that's how always i thought it
was like every every footballers kids
would have been players then that's true
i mean it's like it's like saying that
your child is going to be able to build
a 200 million pound company because you
have
yes i mean it's just not it doesn't
happen because there's so many variables
that can affect that
i guess all you can do is just try and
give them some lessons yeah it's
definitely some advice and it's like
but it's like when you become a parent
it'll be the same your kids don't want
to hear it from you
yeah yeah yeah they don't want to hear
all of this from you yeah
they'd rather hear it from the sunday
league coach you've got no
qualifications and listen to him
and i'm sitting there looking at my son
like do you realize what i have done
what i did why you're here
uh and you're not listening to me you're
not taking my advice that you used to
kill me right but i don't really know
but and then i realized it's more about
just giving them
the tools from a mental perspective to
how to think and live like a
professional
do they know who you are they do it's
weird my son said this to me the other
day he said dad until i got fifa i
didn't really know how good you was you
know
i said what do you mean he says like
you're legend on fifa the game
so now i know obviously i see your stats
they're sick that they're sick how old
is he
he's he's 14. he took him he probably
said only like about until two years ago
when he started playing fifa
that he realized that you like yeah
before that it was looking me
like i was just any man like any guy
like and i say to them like yeah
and one of my sons used to go yeah but
dad
you you really know that though
seriously let's go what's this guy
saying like
what are you talking about i meet you
brother he was like but that's how they
were because they were just oblivious to
it and a lot of players i spoke to and i
asked them did you
know that you were like the top player
not really they don't
really yeah you just want to sit them
down and show them some tapes
yeah but then but you don't sit there
and do that it's like almost like
they've got to go and find it
and that's what they've they've done now
since obviously they go on youtube and
look at stuff as we go down you actually
they're not bad are people saying like
you are the virgil van dyke so who's
better
and like virgil van dyke is here right
who is the best defender in the world in
your view right now yeah yeah
you think it's ramos yeah ramos says
these ages obviously
it works against him but ramos in terms
of influence yeah yeah
um in the last seven or eight years has
been
the standout because he's that he's just
he's been a monster
scores goals scored over 100 goals you
know sent it back really career
yeah crazy but van dyke the last
two years has been the best yeah
liverpool
aren't having a good time at the moment
i'm not guided i'm not good
the best that we've got some liverpool
fans in here and i tell you what i've
i've made the most of this oh it's
beautiful
every day i'm like watching the games i
didn't care before i'm like watching sat
there watching the game
like i'm watching united yeah just like
that oh and then i'll text them all
you've just conceded what's the excuse
today on no fans all that nonsense
no players got an injury yeah heard it
all um
you know you lastly you know you said
you said that you're happy now
happiest you've um you've felt in a long
time yeah
yeah definitely like i'm just i'm facing
that she said i did it
so my face didn't say no you're faced
with no i'm i'm the happiest i've i've
been man it's just because
i don't know i've got three healthy
children four healthy children now got a
newborn baby
family friends um
yeah man it's just
and and business is going well as well
and i can see
st i can see stuff happening and
evolving like
you can almost you can feel stuff
happening you know i mean you must have
felt that with some of the stuff that
you do you feel
you you you get onto something and you
feel momentum a little bit the momentum
starts coming you can see it building so
i'm in a good place man i'm i'm really
happy what do you want
what do you mean what i want i purposely
ambiguous like what do you what do you
want
when you think about what you want now
what is it i just i just want to
be part of something that people go well
that was that's the [ __ ] like that's how
they've done that
fair play well well played that's what i
want why
because that's how i've always been you
play football first and foremost i
wanted
because i wanted to be a success before
that obviously
but that recognition i think we all have
a little bit in us that you want that
recognition
whether it's from your friends your host
network of people family
or outside that but
why why is a football player did you buy
the paper or do you go online
what number's beside your name if you've
got a four out of ten that papers are
getting thrown away
you get a nine attack ten eight ten well
you're looking for that recognition and
i think we've all got a little bit in
that
now why'd you say well done to your team
members of your team because you know
that person
will feed off that recognition so i'm
not ashamed to say that i i'm definitely
like that as well
well thank you so much for for coming
today means a lot and um you're an
incredibly inspiring guy like
and i have no doubt that you're gonna
you're gonna find that thing and it's
gonna
become um just as successful as
everything else you've done in your life
because
you've got all the you've got the
philosophical attributes that are
conducive with
success like you're you're not someone
that got lucky you've clearly got a
mindset that is conducive with success
and especially when you you talk about
how curious you are with things
i like when i say it i mean it like the
way you look at me when i talk about
something that like if i talk about
something that's maybe a little bit
outside of your
realm of experience you might as well
have pen and paper in the hand because
that's the facial expression right yeah
i've got notepads at home
it's going in really so um who i
reference in the podcast is the seo
pretty little thing and he was always
the same and he said to me he was like
i'd get 16 year olds in this office
and i'd be like tell me about tik tok
and he just sits there and studies them
he doesn't know about it he knows about
him
but he will know through them and he'll
learn and he said you should say to me
i'm a sponge he said so mahmoud and
umar would invite me to the office
sometimes four days a week
and i'll just sit in the office and
they'll just ask me questions and then
you'd see them sort of changing their
strategy a little bit on social media et
cetera and
you know their record speaks for itself
but yeah you've been a huge inspiration
for me for many many years as a leader
um as a guy you know i didn't know you
before you know
a couple of years ago and when we met
and the guy you are
and the leader you are is um is
tremendously inspiring you're a good guy
and you're incredibly inspiring as well
so thank you for making the time today
you inspire me now as well so this is uh
kind of it works both ways so i
appreciate you appreciating
thank you cool man thanks
[Music]
you